and I think part of the charm is that
you were in a strip club and then all of
a sudden you've got this huge career and
people like that they identify some way
and and and and the truth be told strip
clubs
was it a horrible existence the
existence did you hate it did you come
to like hate men because I mean I've
seen some weird [ __ ] go down in strip
clubs do you want to know something like
I feel like a lot of people want me to
lie and be like I hated it I went to so
much things I don't I don't I don't
recommend it I don't so curls to go do
it but this is I I'm not even gonna not
even gonna find it really save me like
it really saved me like before I was
working a show club I was the cashier at
a mass market right and being a cashier
didn't go too well for you you got fired
right I know I got fired but it is like
I couldn't move out the situation that I
like I wanted didn't want it to leave
live with my with my ex-boyfriend in his
mother's house but I couldn't even
afford to get all to live in a room I
couldn't I was making like about 250 no
matter how many how many hours I put in
work is just I never made $300 a week
and you were a good student I mean I
mean yeah you got in trouble in school
and stuff but you went to a performing
arts school right I mean you you you you
you had a good education yes you were in
college yes and but you know you go and
you try to make some money so you're
working at the supermarket and didn't
your boss say to you you know what you'd
be better off working at the strip club
across the street yeah like he didn't
say you be but he was like you have a
nice body I'm telling you you should
just work and you should you should work
across the street they make so much
money you look like one of those girls
I'm telling you you know he was turkish
well you nervous to go over there or not
you have to audition you have to
audition and then and then on supper
they're like it's like um I was really
scared because I don't know the type of
things that go down in there like you
know I'm so young and everybody just
down changed down shame stripping a lot
and I feel like oh my gosh do you have
to do
any sexual activity yeah well I was the
same I was dancing naked fully nude or
or with uh with the bottoms long wear
bottoms on bottoms on I just still feel
felt so ashamed for the first couple of
months I used to cry after work like
because all I used to think is like I
could only imagine how embarrassed my my
parents will be the imagery of mine my
mom and my dad came to my head when I
used to give lap dances like I'm so
ashamed of myself but then it's just
like I mean five hundred dollars today
and then it started to I made two
thousand dollars then I made did you
have to tell your parents you were
working in a strip club because at some
point the publisher were you getting all
this money from right no I told my
parents that I was babysitting some
really rich white folks kids